a few days back
we all witnessed a huge downfall in the
crypto market
and due to which many cryptos faced a
lot of backlash
yet there is one cryptocurrency who has
been gathering a lot of attention
towards itself
and that is the shiba inu coin every day
the hype surrounding this crypto is
increasing and everyone
is taking interest in knowing more and
more about this cryptocurrency
hey everyone i'm shamlee and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn
on what is shibainu coin in this video
we will explore about shiva innocoin and
we'll go through some of really exciting
concepts
and components revolving around it
first we will look into the origin of
shiba inu coins
then we will understand what is shibaino
coins
then we will explore how it is different
and unique from dogecoin
then we will figure out why is it so
popular
and at last we will explore what future
shiba inu coin holds
for itself so without wasting more time
let's get started with the video so how
did this shiva unicorn originate
the shiva in a coin was created in
august 2020
by an anonymous person calling
themselves ryoshi
an indian it was intended as an
altcoin of dogecoin which itself was
created as an altcoin of bitcoin and
this meme coin has been named after the
japanese dog breed
shiva inu it feels like the sheba in a
coin was built into existence
and is now insanely popular among major
crypto exchanges
through the power of its following crowd
memes
and a very cute dog now we know how it
originated
so let's have a look at what is shiba in
a coin
shiva inucoin is a decentralized
community building cryptocurrency
or we can say an experiment developed
within the shiva inno ecosystem
and built on top of the ethereum
blockchain network
like many other coins it is a meme coin
launched as a rival of dogecoin a doge
killer
both dogecoin and sheepcoin were made in
a humorous manner
but sheepcoin has already taken over
some dogecoin markets
attracting a lot of attention and rising
as a popular
choice among investors especially after
such
market crash of cryptos like bitcoin and
ethereum
but what is the difference between sheba
and coin and dogecoin
although both shiva inucoin and dogecoin
are meme coins
and share the same tree of origin both
of them differ a lot
from each other at the same time and the
very first difference between them
is the sheep coin is a token and
dogecoin is a currency
let's have a look at more of those major
differences like this
first is development shiba inu coins or
sheep coins
are built on and powered by the ethereum
network
while dogecoin has been developed using
the same technology as bitcoin
then is use cases sheepcoin is still
working upon price more due to its high
popularity
than utility but on the other hand
dogecoin has already established itself
to some extent as a medium of online
payments
there is value according to my coin
market cap
the current value of sheep coin is 0.000
7378 and that of dogecoin is
0.2617
and at last availability the
availability of sheep cointel today
is 394 million and for dogecoin it is
130 billion
now this definitely raises a question in
my mind why is she buying a coin so
popular
shimano coin is majorly popular because
of two reasons
tesla founder elon musk has tweeted
recently expressing that he would like
to own a shiba pub
that hyped the crypto market and prices
rose
by 300 percent on the other hand
its prices fell by around 40 percent
after the founder of
ethereum blockchain network vitalik
buterin donated
50 trillion shebang coins to indian
government
for corporate relief fund of an indian
crypto entrepreneur
sandeep naival
so now that we know about shiba in a
coin and its concepts
let's have a look at what is the future
of shiba inu coins
though sheba coin is only known as a
meme coin
its increasing popularity and people's
interest and participating in it
is pointing towards a different but
bright future
according to investing cube.com the
sheba
coin is predicted to rise again
although there isn't much movement among
this token
and its value active buyers could help
its value rise
the value could rise to
zero 0.000 one zero four zero in a more
active buyers market
although it may not appear to be a
significant amount
due to its popularity in future it can
have a significant influence over large
investors
of the crypto market
well that is all about what chibano coin
is
we have almost reached the end of this
video if i missed anything important do
let me know
in the comment section i hope you
enjoyed this video on what is
shiva in a coin and learn something new
from it
if you like this video then please do
hit the like button
thanks for watching this video and stay
tuned for more updates
and videos from simply done
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here